out of the gate this show was a bit of
phenomena Israel and its massive why do
you think people are latching on to the
series and the way they have well you
know I can only speak like from people
from my generation is that we grew up
with these with these characters and so
to have another shot at them or to have
kind of relive and a nostalgic part of
our lives but in a live-action format to
see it and the way they Roberto and that
all the directors and the actors have
you know brought this story to life I
think they've just done a fantastic job
I think visually it's it grabs you
that's one of the things that really
struck me when I first started watching
it it's like wow this is really
different from something that I've seen
on television or on Netflix or on
anything else it really so it's
beautiful its cinematic yeah and I think
one of the other things which I've
mentioned to your co-stars to is this
guys show could have gone either way you
know could have been really sticky sweet
and like kind of boring in vanilla yeah
but it's kind of done the exact opposite
and it's dark and mysterious and I think
that the yeah sure when I first heard
about this show I was um I was just
reading about in the trades and I I kind
of raised an eyebrow I'm like how do you
do this could you think about kind of
you know the history of the of the comic
it's like I wonder how they can make it
they can grab people and then you watch
it you could you definitely it's not
your you know mom and dad's Archie
comics at all it's you know it's it's
racy it's sexy it's it's beautifully
shot like I said I think the writing is
great the you know I'm really impressed
with the group of actors the the younger
group that they assembled or just the
fantastic let's talk about your
character there's so much mystery
surrounding him do you love playing a
character that's kind of mysterious yeah
I mean look I don't think I've ever been
teed up the way I've been deed up to
come on to a show this character I think
was spoken about a lot in the first
season so that was set up for me and
he's you know he's morally ambiguous you
don't really know where his motives lie
what he cares about at first but I think
as the season goes on you start to
realize what he cares about well that's
kind of one question I wrote down what
is his deal what if what would tell me
what's gonna come up and season two for
him I think you see you know that
aside from all the the the rumors or his
past the one thing that you will see is
that he cares deeply about his family
and whether that sometimes when people
you know care they sometimes think
crosshole I know do you know their
judgment is maybe kind of skewed just a
little bit but at his root
Hyrum really loves his family and will
protect them at any cost would you call
him a bit of a villain Oh a villain
you know I think villain is such a
overused word I would say I like morally
ambiguous I think he don't you know he
he kind of vacillates between doing
exactly the right thing or doing
something that you really wouldn't
expect him to do but if you want to use
the word villain I'll take that because
it's really fun to play have Kelly and
the kids been watching the show yeah
Amanda wasn't one of the great things
about this show is that you know my my
other kids even my older kid who's in
college you know he says he's a
sophomore now he was dad I can hear like
the freshman girls talking about the
show
and then I have a 16 year old high
school student a girl that's just a
death everybody watches this show and
then my 14 year old are so excited about
it and my wife kind of likes Hyrum a lot
she thinks you know it's kind of sexy
she married the right guy she married
yeah you know I was like I can't think
he's a bit of a sociopath that she was
this perfect just be yourself